i'm gonna take my mask down but don't
tell anybody
the bill and melinda gates foundation is
extremely grateful that you and your
household has decided to participate
in our trial halloween is our favorite
holiday there are so many little lab
rats running around
we are excited to present children with
the greatest halloween candy of all
survival that's right we've got the
juice baby
we've worked long and hard several weeks
on this experimental vaccine and we are
super excited about it now you're saying
maybe the children get a little nervous
kids don't like needles
well that's true just like there are
tricks to get children to eat their
vegetables
there are tricks to get them to be
responsible citizens
i'm gonna show you one right now
so look at this it's a bowl of candy
is it or is it the end of covet
that's right kids just put your little
paws in there and grab all you can
bill and melinda are so excited about
the future that they couldn't be here
today they're in an undisclosed location
preparing to go to space
but they have left you in good hands
here at the gates foundation
we realize that some of you are so
excited about the future
we're gonna have to put you in
restraints but we'll do that for you